The joe rogan experience,
but as an individual,
those jobs almost exist to let you know
that you for sure don't want to do that.
It's like the feeling of it being,
it's like being in a
real bad relationship,
right?
Like what?
What gets you out of a relationship?
It he fucking explode.
That's what happens.
You get to a certain point where you like,
will you just shut the
fuck up and leave me alone?
I can't take it as negativity anymore.
We're done.
We're done here.
Okay.
We boom.
Like you have to hit this.
Well,
you got to hit the bottom 15 in order
to change and you've got to have that
Mcdonald's job to appreciate
a really good job.
It's great to talk about later.
Like you and I,
we talked about our first jobs.
It gave you the motivation to get up,
get on your fucking horse
and get out of there.
Yeah.
If you didn't have that motivation,
and that's where when we're talking
about money like our society designed to
sort of encourage motivation
which encourages success,
which encourages financial rewards and
encourages you more attractive to the
opposite sex when you're driving
a Ferrari to a lot of checks.
That's a fact.
A lot of people get really mad at that,
but that's a fact.
It's just the fact,
I mean there's just too many dudes who
are ugly and old who have really hot
wives,
right?
I mean it's just fact.
Guys get billions of dollars in giant
yachts and their fucking these hot chicks
and it doesn't make any sense,
but that's a fact.
You can't deny that fact.
Why is that fact exists?
What exists?
Because we've got a weird system that a
weird system and that's one of the holes
in the system.
One of the holes in the system is that
achievement as as superseded actual
physical desire for a lot of these poor
gold diggers and they let this wrinkly
old cock sucker shoot his dry loads into
you and you got to pretend you love it.
Maybe.
Oh yeah.
Putting them out,
baby you while you're like you like that
guy who got his face farted on through
up at Naga.
That's what you think and this old man
fucking creeps on you and he doesn't
shower on purpose just
to degrade you for today.
If it's all about the money.
Yeah,
why did he suck?
Suck it now baby.
Well,
there's a lot of guys that definitely
have a resentment towards these
goaltenders.
Yeah,
for sure.
Especially once the woman's,
the fun has worn off of the game of
pretending you're attracted to the man,
which you know,
if you're a guy who's not attractive
and you're successful and you believe in
your head that you're something cool,
there's something special about you.
Look how well I've done
and this defines me,
this watch to just watched a $50,000
watch and this is a fucking $20 million
state and you get that shit in your head
and you get a girl and she tricks you
with your own ego.
She can get baby you just
amazing to be a brown.
I'm just so lucky we met each other.
Meanwhile,
she is perfect.
Her tits or just melons bobbing
gently in this really strange,
thin material clothes that she wears,
the clings of her hips and just inches
lower than her vagina just hanging inches
lower than her vagina,
her bubble ass and perfect
leg gap under the pussy hose.
Jesus Christ.
And She just strokes your cock
kisses you and you're like,
I'm marrying this bitch.
She Ain't g yes,
yes,
yes.
Ties.
He's like tire.
She's so,
she gets that Ra
and that's the thing is
you realize with her,
not only am I getting the fucking body,
I'm getting shoulder rubs,
I'm getting subservient to bitch can cook.
She treats the help.
Well,
she gets it and you can go out with her
and she knows how to treat your friends.
She knows how
you and your sleep because she realizes
that she's tricked you into having a
Shitty,
we'll where she gets paid because your
kids are the year she convinced you the
kids would be better off if you didn't
give them a safety net because that would
make them successful like you.
So she played to your ego and you cut
the kids out of the will and gave all the
money in crazy tie bitch who starts
slowly poisoning your drink and she,
she earned it.
That's the thing about like Anna Nicole
Smith when his fucking stupid kids want
it as a state.
No,
Anna Nicole was stuck in his,
didn't,
didn't you?
Still a bit about this.
Fuck yeah,
closers 19 what was it?
What was the whole thing
about them saying like,
oh my God,
she's taking advantage of him.
She's only been,
she's only with him for his money.
I'm like,
don't you think he fucking knows it
kind of made $1 billion from scratch.
Chances are he's a tad crafty and it
was like this whole thing about like how
you want to die.
Do you'd want to get shaking and a low
in your hospital bed surrounded by loved
ones or do you want to get
a big Fat Kentucky Fried
Hooker and just blow it out?
And it was all him dying
telling her to lick his ass.
All the different shit he did
to her right before he died.
And the kids if that nothing.
And they think they deserve.
You were raised with
all that fucking money.
You went to private schools,
you had tennis coaches,
he probably bought you houses.
Why do you need more?
What the fuck did you do?
You didn't suck.
Yeah,
you need to get your own money.
Stupid.
Right?
He rode the ride and now it's over.
And I think also this,
it sounds fucked up,
but that exists because
it's a predatory situation.
You're,
you're prey.
You know,
if you are vulnerable,
old,
weak,
emotional guy who also has $1 billion,
we weren't going to prey on you.
They're going to pretend to
be something they're not.
And they might even been
convinced themselves that
they are that something that
they're pretending to be because their
instinct to try to acquire your wealth
and your social status is so strong
that they want to be the Trump girl.
They want to be the new girl
that Trump leaves his wife for
black and white.
I mean,
if you're a woman that
grew up in that paradigm,
maybe your dad had money and your mother
was a stay at home mom and maybe she
had a a a hint of that and then all of
a sudden you're involved in charitable
organizations and you're
taking his wealth and you're,
you're channeling it to
positive things so you,
it starts to not necessarily be about
is see the one I would've married just
based on his looks and his charisma,
but it starts to become about like,
well,
life is pairing up with
somebody and being powerful.
He watched house of cards.
No,
I haven't,
don't,
don't you fucking spoiler alert me to
say the relationship is about power.
I know that movie,
the show brother is
supposed to be amazing.
Amazing.
Jumping onto it next,
but basically about how a couple can
be together because there are a power
couple and it's interesting.
Bill and Hillary most likely,
right?
Right.
Most likely.
Absolutely.
Mom,
most presidents,
I think probably you have to be,
I don't think you can do
that thing on your own.
I think that's a nutty fucking job.
And the first lady has a
prominent role in our culture.
I mean,
she's constantly speaking and doing these
things and I think you're dead right.
I think you're dead right about that.
And I think,
um,
it's also that we're also talking about
just two stops on a broad range of
possibilities from ultimately totally
evil Russian hot prostitute who steals
your organs when you're asleep to
someone who just doesn't want to work.
And the guys kind of cool and he treats
her good and so she stays with them.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm,
I've seen both.
I've seen,
I've seen people get victimized and I've
seen people that are just in sort of
these relationship where
I wouldn't want it,
but it works for them.
Sometimes they're out in the other one
that the woman will tease and be like,
oh,
how'd he sat?
You know,
I wouldn't be with you if it
wasn't for the fucking money.
Oh,
it's not even a team.
He goes,
of course I know that that's
a movie that's in a movie.
What was the movie that was in,
there was a movie that
was in where the tune,
well,
no,
the watch,
Schindler's list terms of Indiana.
You can't even help it.
You do it right away.
Fucking platoon picture into
Oregon's hanging out on the beach.
Um,
I forget the movie man.
Uh,
but it was just about,
about a guy who lost everything
and in the scene like his,
his wife was like laughing about
it when everything was going great.
And then when he did lose all the money,
she did fucking leave them.
Well actually it was in the
wolf of Wall Street too.
It's a common theme and
the wolf of Wall Street,
obviously it was a crazy coked
up fucking maniac piece of shit.
But when he was going under and
his business was going under,
that's when the wife left him.
When he was doing great.
The wife wanted him when he
was married to another woman.
I mean like it was,
it was a classic story.
So it's not like that's an
unfamiliar paradigm to us.
It's nature.
It's a wounded antelope
that gets taken out by the,
the line.
It's and she needs somebody to
provide for her or she doesn't.
But in that role she does,
if she chooses that role,
if she chooses the role of fucking the
old wrinkly shaky man with his fucking
Pale translucent dick
that he sticks inside,
we could see as he's coming,
could see the veins like pump whatever
blood they've got and it's like a little
highway going down his fucking
Saran wrap skin filled with Viagara.
Yeah,
and just shooting dust
bubbles into her pussy.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
I mean that's something her nipples,
you can take that choice or you know,
you could start an art gallery and
become a multimillionaire on your own.
I mean,
you could do that too.
You know it's,
but when you are that girl,
okay,
if you are that 25 year old girl than
Adderall problem that's looking to try to
hook up with some old billionaire dude
and marry him so they'd be taken care of
for life.
You're that.
That's your role.
That's what you've chosen.
You might have more potential than that,
but it doesn't mean that
that's not what you've chosen.
Oh,
you don't even know,
baby.
She's so slick.
She's so smart.
I mean,
that is one of the smartest
girls I've ever met in my life.
When she met him and she put together,
it doesn't matter.
You're talking nonsense.
She's still that girl.
She's a prostitute.
You can't say no,
no,
no.
Listen,
you can't say she's a prostitute
and I know her and she's powerful.
And what she did was like,
she's really clever and she figured
out what admit be like guys.
No,
no,
no.
She's still prostitute.
You're missing the whole point,
right?
So it doesn't matter if
she has all this potential.
She reads 150 bucks a week.
Okay,
don't fucking tell me that
girl is so goddamn smart.
Oh my God.
You're saying she's not smart.
Go see she's a hooker.
She's playing the role of a hooker
beset in terms of a female and a male,
because sometimes women are so hot that
the guy is getting something out of her
and he's putting up with not,
not having love,
not having respect for her,
but wanting that pussy so bad or that
status of being with somebody that's that
hot that it is.
Same Way.
He's a prostitute for what
he's getting from her.
Oh yeah.
There's certainly,
I mean there's exchanges other
than money that are unfair.
The reason the old man gets the girl
in the first place is because of his
fucking money.
That's it.
So when he's honest vote,
people know what they're getting sort of.
But it's not because they're playing
a game called love in the game is BB,
I'd love you.
I'm just so happy to be with you.
Oh,
you love me.
Do you want some Dick?
I thought your tech baby.
But in the law they're playing a game.
Somebody wins and the
show is a winner or loser.
He gets pussy drive,
Pussy.
If she drugs him and surprise.
Well,
it's a matter about
maintaining that relationship.
And this allowing her to
fuck her personal trainer.
Right.
He's going to share.
Okay.
She's going to look how hot she is.
She's got this little waste,
this dynamic body.
She's 25 years old and you're
90 she's gonna fuck her trainer.
Just accept it.
Be happy that you could fuck
her and don't ask questions.
Hagar is supposed to work out early out,
open dosed with just this smile.
Yeah.
Ritual,
man.
She won't have to worry.
It's fucking Great Eagle's song,
man.
You can't hide your lying eyes man.
It's a fucking jam jam.
Cause when you met your wife,
you were already very successful.
You had money on me.
I had my girl,
I fucked up because I was
single when I met my girl,
my now wife,
and it's fucking,
I had an MTV game shell and I was like,
I met her at the wrong fucking time,
lined up so much.
But that's not true because you,
you enjoyed it.
See everybody's worried
about what they are,
but you still do.
But everybody's worried
about what they didn't do.
Right.
This is a no,
I should have done this.
No,
you shouldn't have dry.
I've had people in my life to tell
me the most important thing that ever
happened to them was fucking up.
Because if you fuck up,
then you realize you fucked up.
And that's what motivates you to
get away from fucking Mcdonald's.
I should've never done that.
Of course you should have done it.
I lost everything.
I fucked up getting that marriage,
man.
You should have fucking gotten married.
You should have lost everything now.
You know,
you win.
Now you,
when you got the knowledge,
you'll never let it happen again.
Don't use this as an excuse to
just wallow in your own system.
Then worse than the wallowing
fucking divorce guy.
You know,
he's living in a condo and in Marina del
Ray and he's fucking go to the same bar
every night and the same stuff.
He's one of those guys were like,
the woman at Starbucks knows his name
because his life has become so simplified
and dumbed down because he's afraid
to move forward after a divorce.
Eddie Bravo used to be a DJ,
a strip club when we first met.
And,
um,
Eddie introduced me to the game of how
these girls would go about getting men to
buy them things.
Like I'd be friends with these
girls and knew him through him.
So they were like,
they were nice people,
you know,
and I didn't have relationships with them
so I was just talking to them and they
would tell me about these guys that
they were hooking up with that would buy
them cars and shit and
how they would do it.
So I visited him at work and a,
I'm like,
what's going on man?
And he's like,
ah,
nothing dude.
Check this out.
You're going to talk to this girl.
And then her,
one of her clients,
when she comes in,
like you got it.
You got to see like this
guy just bought her a truck.
He bought her like a Yukon Denali.
And so the girls hanging out and you know,
hanging out with your friends.
And this guy comes in who was,
there's a classic story.
It was a wounded gazelle.
55 year old divorce guy works for the
post office coming in with his postal
jacket on.
He's norm from cheer.
He bought her a $35,000 car man.
And this guy,
he bought her a fucking Yukon Denali,
you know,
it was a nice car,
maybe $35,000,
the wrong number.
I'm just throwing it out there,
whatever it is.
He bought her a new car.
So,
um,
she sees him and she goes,
oh.
And she runs over like little baby steps,
like a girl and she's fucking naked man.
She's naked.
She's in her underwear.
She got a bikini on and she goes
over and gives us guy a hug.
And you could see this guy is defenseless.
There's no way in the world that a girl
that looks like that would ever have
that kind of reaction to him.
So he's got to pay for that.
You got to pay for that and you got to
pay for it by buying her a car or taking
care of her fucking credit problem
that she's got or you know,
do whatever.
You got to figure out how to pay for that
shit because there's no other way that
you're going to get that relationship.
But when I watched it,
I was like,
I looked at Eddie and he was like,
that's shit straight mercenary.
Right.
And I was like,
this is crazy.
Like they just,
they put a con game on these guys.
I got a friend who's like,
he seems to like make friends
with rich people and I,
he's a good guy but it's weird.
And uh,
he says that a few of these guys,
they really do take care of girls.
They've got like an apartment
in New York that she lives in.
She gets a check every month.
I mean figure it costs them 50 grand a
year and these are guys that have fucking
$30 million.
So to have a relationship set up when
when they come to town they don't have to
call an escort service and they don't
have to go out and try to make a straight
relationship with,
they have to send flowers
and call every day.
They come to town,
she's fucking gorgeous.
P You know,
powerful,
confident.
It's all on the table and they've
got like three city set up and it's,
and when,
when he comes to town,
she is a available 24 seven
whatever the fuck he wants.
And I bet they have some kind
of friendship underneath at all.
Maybe not.
Well,
that would be great if it
all worked out like that,
right?
If,
if,
if that was the arrangement and
it all worked out like that.
Right?
But the problem with people is there's no,
there's never really a static state
maintains itself for any long periods of
time when it comes to relationships.
You're either kind of all in or you had
drift in and out of each other or she
finds another guy.
I mean,
people were weird.
They did.
It's very difficult to make.
So how are you going to maintain
the longterm prostitutional
relationships right
here?
Not most likely people that begin with,
yeah,
most likely mean you're painted
out to be awesome and beautiful.
But the reality is that's
not what the girl wants.
She wants to find a guy either if she
wants someone to take care of her,
she wants to find a guide to take care
of her and her lover and her boyfriend or
her husband or whatever.
And for this guy that thinks that
he's going to like maintain it,
you're going to have to manage
each one of these situations.
If you're some crazy CEO
of some giant corporation,
you got like four apartments scattered
out across the country with checks living
in them.
You've got to maintain these positions
like who's who's fucking her when you're
not there,
what's happening is anybody
planning your death,
you better be sure you know,
do,
what did you sign?
You sign anything crazy.
You know that.
Does she have any
photographs of your Dick?
Like we'd get for a credit card?
Did you give her a credit card?
Well,
it's like you do,
you'd have to monitor these situations.
This ain't going to be a normal person.
It's going to be a person's willing
to fuck you because you pay for them.
Right.
And you know,
they might be crazy.
Yeah,
easily might be crazy.
I heard this dude,
I was at the w and a sitting in the lobby
waiting and this is dude sitting next
to me and he's got an accent,
sound Scandinavian and he's going,
uh Oh fuck I get you on the phone.
You've been so hard to reach lady baby.
Uh,
you know,
you know I,
I,
I'm so crazy but you're so beautiful.
I can't wait to get you out.
You need to stop going to college.
You come in,
I take care of,
he never met her and he
was talking on the phone,
clearly met on some kind
of high end dating service
where you get women that you
take care of that she was flirting back
and they were making plans for her to
fly out for a week.
He was going to take her to
the best restaurants in La,
blah blah.
And I was telling her all the
things he's going to bribe her with.
Right.
And he had seen pictures online.
They had talked on the phone clearly
a few times and he was closing.
He was making the
arrangements to fly her out.
Okay.
Why do we have a problem with that?
Why does anybody have a
problem with should been right?
One's eyes are open.
I don't think,
I think all prostitution
should be legalized.
I think that whorehouses
I think that having having horizontal
street or having to go through Craig's
list is,
it's horrible.
The reality is people
are going to use Horace,
put it on the table,
legalize it,
make them get tested for STDs,
make sure they're keeping their money.
They're not getting
fucking beaten up and uh,
and relationships like
this should be fine.
Yeah.
Well unbelievably
fascinating that you have something that
everybody wants and everybody gets for
free.
But as soon as you money to it,
it has this massive stigma to it.
Like,
you know,
saying that these prostitution
and relationships aren't stable,
what relationships are,
you know,
are you,
you hook up with someone,
is that going to be stable if you just
meet people randomly and have sex with
him?
He agreed to have sex with each other.
Is that going to be stable?
You sure it might not be stable either.
You might run into instability
everywhere you turn,
but the main reason why we,
how all these negativity,
negative ideas attached to the idea of
prostitution is because it's illegal.
What if you hookup one
night with a cheque?
You bought dinner,
you bought drinks,
you paid for the cab,
back to the apartment,
you spent all the money.
You guys fuck.
How is that different than how
handing the girl money and having sex?
So there,
how about all those things are just you
dating and there's nothing wrong with
being nice and being nice to someone
and taking a friend out or drive in them
around taking them to a nice restaurant.
Nothing wrong with that.
But then what does she says,
I've got this situation,
um,
I'm three months Martin and my rent
and I don't know what's doing you like,
look,
I'll just take care of it.
And you write her a check and
then she sucked your Dick.
What happened there?
Right?
Did you pay for her to Suck Your Dick?
We don't know.
She might've stopped you dick.
Anyway,
you might've been like,
listen baby,
you know you don't get money from me,
but you do get Dick and you pull
your dick out and then she blows you.
That's different.
Right.
But most guys can't pull that off.
What about,
what about a marriage where the wife
does that work has never earned a dime.
She's having sex with you.
[inaudible] that's prostitution according
to some people according to some
people.
It's certainly is.
I mean according to a lot of male
feminists who would be right,
right?
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's money coming in sex going out.
I mean if that's what you want to look at,
but it's agreements.
It's the problem is the idea of money.
It's agreements you,
that's where the idea
of prostitution sort of,
it comes down to what it comes down to
is are people having sex with people that
they might not necessarily have
been willing to without any benefit,
but that benefit exists so
they are willing to do it.
Is that prostitution?
Because if it,
if that benefit is only money,
then the,
you're,
you're defining sex for
something as sex for money,
that's prostitution.
But everything is sex for something.
Yeah.
If you see,
like you were talking about
the Ferrari thing before,
if you're at a club and a,
you see a guy pull up in a Ferrari
and you go home with that guy.
Part of the reason you went home
with him is you saw the Ferrari.
There's not dollars exchanged,
but there is an implicit understanding
this dude's got money and he spends it
like a fucking lunatic.
Yup,
and you want to be around that.
That's a good point that he
spends it like a fucking lunatic.
That's a great point because
that's really what it is.
A guy who's so flashy,
he's driving a $250,000 car.
He's not going to hesitate to give
you a couple of grand here and there,
right.
You know,
you want to buy a new pair of shoes.
He's like,
here,
I don't fucking peels off some hundreds,
right.
Gives you a kiss on the cheek
and goes back to doing business.
Buy,
sell,
buy,
sell the fucking some crazy.
Right?
Multimillionaire Maniac
banker dude's right.
It's a party and you just got invited.
You're going to be around this fucking,
this guy who doesn't give a about money.
He knows he's gonna die soon because he's
on Adderall and he's chained smoke and
he's a drunk,
and wherever you go,
you're eating the best steaks.
You're getting into the best clubs.
Life is fucking good.
Oh yeah.
And I'm fucking him.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's that.
At the end of that Ivan's wife and every,
when you show up the country club,
oh miss nick 11 Prius.
Come on in and you've got a
little poodle with you and you,
you fucking walking your $3,000 shoes
and he waddled in there and take your
tennis lesson,
your tennis player,
fucking bones,
you in the locker room.
Then the husband says,
bring him over.
I want to watch.
Oh Jesus,
I ain't got so ugly.
A lot of guys won't do that,
but I don't think that's a normal thing.
No,
I don't think that's
watching a lot of the watch.
That's a weird thing.
And then the cock hold porn,
just Latino cuckold porn.
Where do you find that?
I haven't really seen
once typing cuckold porn.
Don't do it,
Brian,
Huh?
Okay.